o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é o dark
ae é um gênio e sejam muito bem vindos e
mais de um quilo a boca quando o estrago
de que um vídeo com alguns livros de
ataque enfiado na minha cabeça e saiu há
pouco tempo um filme que o ensine
strecht não sei se você já viu um ou
dois mas que o filme está o sim eu já vi
basicamente este é um jogo que trata
s/no do filme ou seja vou entrar dentro
do filme
vou passar pela experiência do filme e
vai ser o são porque tito filmes e
alguns hits é do [ __ ] moneo é do são
paulo acho que já fiz um vídeo deste ano
acho que estava dentro de uma mansão
assombrada uma coisa sem partido vai
ficar aí que i chega chega já clicaram
tartan pois vem agora preferência o que
só estamos aqui dentro de uma sala com
uma porta à minha frente e eu por
exemplo estou sentado numa ideia não sei
que o equipamento mancada enfrenta uma
porta é suportável não crê que o suposto
fazer o aluno longe falou vai até e
pediu que a brutal e agora estou a
adorar até agora não acontece nada és tu
é que fechar a conta pouco o rosto
jovial estava quem é esta mulher é esse
ninguém quem isto tudo dentro de uma
casa igual o igualmente está muito real
disse ao china anfitriã ea indicação
para o que fazer
tem mãe e o senhor pensão eo edil não
vai só que em tamanho pequeno não vai
cair vai usar
ae o deputado argumenta meu estou quase
a torre muito útil sou eu entendi que se
chama venda sua espiã da austrália onde
estendem outubro não vencer em si mas
pode ser só vinha
talvez eu e os meus passarinhos toque
rápido de parceria já o fundo que está a
passar pela ajuda
venha jogando muito ela durma em som o
que é um bom entendimento strong até
mesmo o odor e isto tudo isso tudo isto
oitavo game chinelo alguém mexer nela é
talea alguém mais velho ajuda
não eu não estava nem aí porque está
tudo escuro um texto velha qualquer
coisa
o roubo ao uol não é não
quem não está a pensar não não tem muito
jeito não há muita gente não estava
nenhum banco está bom é realista parece
mesmo que a mulher tá aqui não toques
conheceram nojenta
cleiton roque numa velha
ok você mandar um pouco da outra vez
tudo isso removi etc
o ok pessoal pelos vistos foi só mesmo
isso eu penso que o jogo fosse maior e
até mas vamos ficar por aqui só com este
jogo está o brutal aumento global do
sério eu tive mesmo tempo espero que
vocês alguma coisa boa para alguns hits
e via lista e assustadora e isto mudou
uma cueca vejo como eu tô suado no
início essas ervas e ó só espero que
vocês tenham gostado
deixa eu falar que o favorito agora vou
tomar um banho por parece uma porca que
toda suada mas é isso contra o blackpool
brito fica bem e até a próxima é com as
melhor